all right leah so what's sparking this
move right now what's going on
great to be back charles thanks so much
so look i think what's really sparking
this rally is the fact that the market
now has more clarity previously we saw
many whales custodians major companies
taking very risky positions as a result
many of them have actually been
liquidated and so we're now at a point
where
most of the leverage has actually been
flushed out the market giving the market
this opportunity to reset now because
bitcoin has been able to remain roughly
around twenty thousand dollars um that's
a key psychological support level
because that was the high of the
previous bull market so now retailers
are starting to fomo back in because
they believe that this could actually be
um the bottom so they don't want to miss
the opportunity to buy as much bitcoin
as possible at the potential bottom of
this market but i do want to make clear
that this could possibly be a bear
market rally it's very normal during uh
bear markets to actually see different
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin and
ethereum start to rally but to anywhere
from 20 to 50 between one to two weeks
and we saw this in 2018 and 2019 um so
all you have to do is zoom out and see
that there is this downward trend
unfortunately right now um so this
possibly could be a bear market rally
but but having said that you know i've
had a fair amount of bitcoin guests on
in the last two weeks and some have said
it could go to 14 000 others even 10
thousand
you know is it dangerous though to try
to gain this if you're you know i mean
we know a lot of tourists and media
types had kicked the tires they threw it
in a towel but for folks who are really
seriously considering this i'm looking
at the chart i think it closed above 24
000. i don't see anything in a way to 29
30 000. so you know do you play that
game of trying to pinpoint the bottom
with bitcoin
like you should never try and time the
market and i definitely think that 10
000 bitcoin in this current market right
now short term is definitely possible we
do have to consider the geopolitical
situation um there's a war going on
between russia and ukraine um you know
europe is very unstable right now and
all these things are going to affect the
market inflation you've been talking
about that on your show obviously that's
going to affect the market quantitative
tightening as a result of inflation and
we're now seeing more of interest rates
globally are going up and as a result
that does start to actually strengthen
the us dollar and when that happens um
other alternative asset classes like
bitcoin and other luxury goods do start
to um depreciate so let me jump right
here once again i'm a financial advisor
i've got less than 30 seconds but
the action in the last two weeks uh
bitcoin versus gold do you think it's
making the case a greater case that
maybe this is indeed truly that hedge
against inflation and everyone said it
was
it really depends when you buy bitcoin
right because ultimately if you buy
bitcoin um and you hold it for five
years you're going to be in the green
and you're going to be up which means it
is that hedge against inflation it's not
very smart to start buying an asset at
the top of a bull market which many
people did and so the best thing to do
is always zoom out have it five year
long term plan and then yes it can act
as a much better hedge against inflation
than gold all right leah thank you very
much appreciate